[Music]
danielle is in tampa florida hi danielle
how are you
hi mr randy thank you very much for
taking my call sure what's up
um i'm in a position where i'm thinking
about selling my house
my son's father and i live together and
it's not the best situation
um
your blinds.com advice actually was
pretty spot-on as far as our situation
goes
um i've connected with one of your elps
and i'm just really torn because i love
my home and i love my neighborhood but i
just want to be able to pay my debt off
and provide better for my son
okay uh so you own the home
with your boyfriend or
no sir it's just me you own it
yeah
okay
um
when is he leaving
uh that's a great question
well i'll give you the answer
tonight
i can hear it no no i can hear it in
your voice
you sound really afraid to me
yeah well i'm trying to talk to you
outside and he's actually standing next
to me because she can't go inside
sir
um i have about 16 000 worth his worth
of debt um it includes a car a credit
card the medical debt from the birth of
our son
that
i get no helpless yeah um
my home
your elp said that i could potentially
walk away with about 88 000. yeah so i
could reasonably take all that off i
could
set my son up and myself up in a nice
townhome or a reasonable town home in a
nice area
good schools you have shot all this out
what is your income
uh
i just got a promotion at my job i've
been there about 10 years um i don't
quite know what it works out to me but
it's 21 an hour i believe it's like 44.
okay how old are you
i'll be 32 this monster how old your
baby
eight months
[Music]
okay um
i don't know if you need to sell your
house or not
you may
that's possible
but that's not your problem today is it
yes sir yeah
okay do you have family in the area
i do
um my mom passed away about two years
ago unfortunately so
um i still have my dad and brothers and
oh you're you have daddy you have a
father and brothers in the area
yes i am my grandma my aunt who would
have room for me and charlie my son
okay um you need to get in the car and
go to your dad's house when you hang up
the phone
i can't do that i've tried that early
why can't you do that
do i need to call the police for you
no sir we've already gone through that
oh well i'm about to go through it again
where are you danielle are you outside
your house right now
yes i am you are okay do you have car
keys where's charlie where's your
where's your son
in uh his father's
end in front of my car
all right you need to uh
when you hang up you need to call the
police you need to call your father
and you need to get you and your son
away from the sky do you hear me
do you understand
this is not going to work otherwise
honey
this is not a house problem and it's not
a debt problem
you and your son are in danger
do you understand me
hello
yes sir
i'm sorry
where'd you go
sir can you hear me yeah i can where are
you okay okay i'm sorry
did you hear what i said or were you
distracted yes i did sir no i heard you
okay
so are you going to sit there
in the middle of the sewage or are you
going to fix it
i want to fix it that's why i want to
tell my home and i just want to go no no
honey we don't need to call a realtor
we need to get the boyfriend out of the
house and that's going to involve the
police and or your father and your
brothers
he needs to leave it's your house
and you're afraid
you understand that this is wrong right
yes sir okay this is this is you're
you're not the crazy one
i'm talking to the same one you know
what a lot of times it feels like that
yeah i know
all right i'll tell you what we're going
to do
we're going to put you on hold and kelly
is going to make sure that law
enforcement gets over there okay no sir
don't you please no baby doll
i'm not going to be i'm i'm not
i love you and that baby
do what
just you don't know if i should still
like how to not
i'm sorry i'm sorry it's just okay
it's okay honey
you're you're you're right
i trust you
listen listen easy breathe
you're in a horrible situation and you
have to make the moves to get away from
it
okay
and part of part of the type of
situation that you are in
is that part of his psychological job is
he has convinced you that you're not
able to operate without him
and i'm convinced the only way you're
ever going to be able to operate is
without him
you understand me
yes sir okay
you listen you are worth
being okay
it's worth being okay for your kid
it's worth being okay it's your freaking
house
he's
trespassing we're gonna remove the
trespasser
it has to happen okay you have to get
away from this guy
anyone who calls a national radio show
and is in this kind of distress
tells me that there's serious stuff
going on inside your walls
you understand and then once he's clear
we're going to put you with one of our
counselors
free i'm not going to charge you a dime
and we're going to walk with you and
then we can start making decisions about
your finances
but you don't have a financial problem
you need a boyfriend ectomy
[Laughter]
and it's happening today darling
it's happening today
do you understand
yes sir today and danielle if you feel
like you need
you and your son to be somewhere safe
then i would get out of the house as
well
removing him may not
well not you know but i mean after he's
gone you can make this determination you
may need to go to local law enforcement
but you know get a restraining order you
can do whatever you need to do at that
point but you and the baby need to get
out of there until he's gone and then
you need to get someone to remove him
and it's that simple
so
um
that's what you have to do and then you
can begin to have a conversation
uh in some form of sanity
because the situation you are in right
now is insane
it's an insane situation you're not
insane
but the situation's crazy girl
thank you sir
thank you hey we love you you hold on a
second kelly's gonna pick up okay and
we're gonna make sure you get taken care
of you weren't scheduled to be involved
in the show yesterday but you got
involved behind the scenes a little bit
yeah
for those of you that were not around
yesterday for whatever reason
i don't usually tell you what yesterday
is but all that but this is the time
we're going to stop and do that
we had a young lady call in with rachel
and i on the air that um
became apparent during the call that she
was
a victim of domestic violence which i
don't even like saying that that way
because it sounds so antiseptic she was
a victim of her boyfriend beating the
crap out of her is a better way of
saying the truth
and we determined that and uh then
while we were on the call we determined
he was in the room that he had walked in
and was not happy and so um
uh it went from a financial question to
a question of her safety and her child's
safety and so forth on the air
live
pretty wicked weird
and wild but um walk her through that a
little bit and um
john just happened to walk by the studio
and stepped in and
i put her on hold and he does a lot has
done a lot of
trauma and uh crisis uh intervention
type counseling over the years and so um
trained in that but also experienced in
that so we got you got on the phone with
her and
um we were able to get the uh the police
over there very quickly and uh the young
man is sitting where he should be now in
a cage
um which is where people like that
belong um
and so i think they call that a jail but
i called it a cage um very simple either
one is very simple either one's fine
with me but they're both similar
situation here this is where this little
guy needs to be
and uh so that was pretty wild
discussion you were having in there off
air yeah i i noticed at one point i
didn't know who would who was in there
you know you kind of zone out and lock
try to lock
in in face to face you lock eyes but in
those situations you lock hearts with
somebody and then i noticed you'd come
in there after a while but yet it was
intense mainly because it was live it
was happening live and she was
not it wasn't philosophically unsafe she
was unsafe now and somebody else had her
kid and then you've got a mom who needs
to protect herself
but i'm not going to leave my baby
unprotected and now you've got a messy
situation
and
whenever i show up to something like
that i'm always looking at escalation
trends is this thing slowing down are
people separating and they just yelling
at each other or is it moving up and
this one moved up real rapidly
and um luckily that police department
there was super responsive and they
showed up and um grateful to them and
at the end of the day man we're talking
to a really brave brave young woman
brave new mom and she's got a hard row
ahead of her but yeah things got pretty
dicey there for a minute yeah and that's
not that's not us hollywoodizing this
thing you know it got pretty nice
it was very real yeah and uh he's a
violent dude
and uh so
the uh
yeah of course so the end of the story
is she's safe her family's around her
and of course we're gonna uh we've
plugged her in with financial counseling
she does have some crisis financial
situation as well and she's got some
resources there some domestic violence
he was not even on the table for
discussion yesterday so but our team is
rallying around her we're plugging her
in with counselors not of course no
charge and we're just going to walk with
her and make sure she gets
gets her life uh changed in a different
direction because it sure was going down
the toilet pretty fast there and we did
we connected her to some
domestic violence resources there in
tampa too so that she can have a local
community that can be hands-on there
yeah and yeah so so she's safe and good
for those of you that were listening a
lot of you've been
you know emailing us and worried and so
forth and uh so we thought we would give
you guys a bit of an update and you know
it's odd you and i were talking i think
it was last week on the air
about this correlation between um
extreme control over money issues and
domestic violence
that there's a correlation between that
because there's this
where uh where a husband or a boyfriend
it will not let you pick the cereal at
the grocery store you can't go grocery
shopping by yourself you can't buy
detergent you can't do anything without
his approval on every little nuanced
thing where there's that level of weird
toxic control over
a lady
a woman uh
with the money it's it's a high
statistical indicator that he's probably
hitting her
it's just about power right and i'll
take that power over i can get it yeah
it's about power and control and boy he
you know that was going on yesterday and
you could smell it in the air so i put
her on the
air it was um
it didn't take a genius to figure out
what was to you know to figure out what
i was dealing with what we're going into
there but you know i think the
the thing that um
you can't get away from
on the positive side
or the negative side of toxic toxic
behaviors
is that um
our behaviors is that personal finance
is 80 behavior it's only 20 head
knowledge so the chances of you being in
a relationship that are that
dysfunctional and being wealthy yeah
uh becoming wealthy in a dysfunctional
setting is just almost impossible right
because these things don't live in one
nice little compartment over here
uh and then not bleed over or not not
bad bad metaphor but don't don't reach
over into the other areas of your life
absolutely i mean you can't be
a punching bag in one area of your life
and then suddenly be prosperous and
healthy and
uh
winning at your career and winning at
your wealth building that kind of they
just don't it's not we can't
compartmentalize that tight right and
one of the challenge with relational
abuse of any kind is
you accept that as a given
you accept that as
well some days are good days
occasionally he'll come and cry and say
and he's sorry and it's going to be okay
and so you start trying to solve that
inner chaos at the margins you start
trying to think of well maybe i can get
a better interest rate or maybe i should
trade my car in or it's probably my job
and you're and you distance yourself
from this core nuclear reactor issue
that is hey you're not safe your baby's
not safe and this thing just escalates
this way right so um to anyone the
decisions you make on the money on the
fringes to avoid the nuclear reactor at
the center are never good decisions
they're not because you're making them
out of chaos right well and you're
making them uh too
in order to mask that's right and in
order instead of dealing with with the
core issues and so you know larry
burkett used to say dead is not the
problem it's the symptom there you go
and so it's a symptom of a behavior well
i heard you say something yesterday
through the window that i think is worth
reiterating
you look listened to her and you said
hey hon you are worth being safe you're
worth more than this and so anybody
listening
is in any sort of abusive situation
exhale and drop your shoulders for a
second and look up in the rearview
mirror if you're driving and look in the
mirror at your house you're worth being
safe
so can the wall street journal reads the
irs wants to look at your bank account
on your next trip to the atm imagine
that uncle sam's looking over your
shoulder as if your annual tax filing
wasn't invasive enough the biden
administration would like to look at
your checking account charles reddig the
commissioner of the internal revenue
service wants banks to report annual
cash flows for ordinary account holders
treasury secretary janet yellen is
promoting the plan and the
house ways and means committee is
debating whether to include this mandate
in the democrats 3.5 trillion dollar
spending bill mr yellen says the
reporting will help to catch wealthy tax
dodgers in a recent letter to the
committee she said the plan would reveal
opaque income streams that
disproportionately accrue to the top
yeah the re the wealthy are evil and i'm
sure they're all hiding their money in
the bank you stupid woman
seriously
well this is uh this is unbelievable had
had i not seen that this was an actual
article i would have thought this was a
spoof from the onion
this is so unbelievably outrageous
that the federal government is kicking
around the idea of being able to look
into our bank accounts let me tell you
something this is going to get nasty
right here because uh there's there's
always another way around it every time
government tries to move and pivot to
take away our personal freedom uh people
figure it out and i hope some bankers
are paying attention right now because
if i i i i can you imagine something can
you imagine that this would not help
deposits
that's what i'm saying yeah it's going
to disrupt and destroy an industry i got
to tell you the irs plans to review
every account above a 600 balance
or because that's the people that are
these are the wealthy tax dodgers here
well there's the catch it's not about
wealthy people it's about everybody yeah
it's about control
again it's time for some pitchforks to
come out i got a
little bit of a
probably a couple of uh torches to go
with the pitchforks yes it's also a
privacy breach waiting to happen not
long ago the confidential tax records of
just bezos mike bloomberg and other
wealthy americans were exposed by
pro-publica
whoever leaked or hacked those records
committed a crime but the irs has
revealed nothing from its promised
investigation adding bank account info
to the irs trove would dis risk the
disclosure of savings and spending
information of political adversaries in
the same way no that would never happen
23 state treasurers and auditors signed
a letter last month opposing the plan
calling it one of the largest
infringements of data
privacy in our nation's history you
think
by the way watch this watch how this
might just flood the cryptocurrency
thing becoming an outside fringe thing
to an actual everyday thing that's why
this thing is out there i'm not
endorsing it at all i don't do anything
with it i want to be very clear but
that's where this is coming from
because of this government overreach you
watch it it's just gonna if this happens
or even tries to happen it's to create a
tidal wave of of mistrust and all kinds
of problems it's laughable it's so
absurd
it really is it's it's mind-blowing that
that they think that this could actually
happen
yeah and and you know i would think
that probably one of the more powerful
lobbying groups
even for democrats would be the bankers
abs that's why i laugh and i would think
that they would put their big heel on
this and grind
because this is going to create
a lot of cost for them
because they have to build systems to
report this to comply
this is like this is a billions and
billions of dollars of cost for the
banking industry yeah
yeah the th this my god if you got 750
joe biden wants to know it oh yeah and
first of all let me just say this i i
have no this is an opinion i just don't
think this has any legs to at all it's
so ridiculous
but the emperor is officially not
wearing clothes that's where we are
right now this is such an unfortunate
transition
yes on top of everything else he's
taking his clothes birthday suit needs
earnings don't do that yes it does don't
do that it's just so absurd that this
that this policy would even be floating
no it's just
but it's
you know it it goes along with a lot of
the covet overreach and some of these
other things that are overreaching
constitutional rights
um
and it's been going on for some time yes
and uh
just how much
before people bow up on it um i think
this would do apparently there's a
weather problem with southwest air right
now yeah weather the weather everywhere
southwest air is flying is bad yeah and
so uh they're struggling with weather
and everywhere they land is a problem
yeah
so yeah
this is gonna this has
these
statements and policies and supposed
things even if you don't implement them
if you just toss it out there like a
trial balloon that has a grenade
attached to it uh it still has
implications that's a great point you
know reverbs through these industries
that's absolutely a great point dave
this is a threat to privacy
a threat
right now it's a threat it's not an
attack yet but it's a threat and i don't
know if there's anything more private
than our bank accounts you start talking
about people's money
i mean we're talking you've been doing
this for a long time we're talking
crazy emotions around
oh your money and the privacy of that
yeah this is a threat to privacy that's
what this is yeah it's it's like a a
banana republic where you can't trust
the banking system so you have to keep
your money under a mattress
and you have to stay off the grid
because you can't it's not trustworthy
that's correct why they steal the cheat
and you know some of these crazy
countries and if we're are we going to
devolve into that with this kind of
movement out of the federal government
of course the good news is we've got a
group of governors
on several of these issues that are
saying uh your overreach doesn't extend
across our state line
we're not going to allow it and then
we've got another group of governors
that went oh yeah we're all in uh
whatever you want to do
we're with you big joe
yeah this is out of control
out of control the tyranny is uh is real
so yeah just let them poke around in
everybody's bank account
not to mention how much that costs not
to mention how much you do but every
time you get ready to move your money
that you earned they want to know about
it
uh
yeah we'll see how that works out
this
is the ramsey show up next is gonna be
chris in los angeles hi chris welcome to
the ramsay show
hey dave how are you doing great man
what's up
um there's a couple things one you uh
you've done some great work and in some
ways i love you
in other ways you're stupid and arrogant
okay
how can i help you all right by the way
that's a great way to start any
conversation right there
yeah well
my first question would be are you
smarter than warren buffett
how old are you
because you push i'm 35 okay cool
so what i'm sorry
let's stop just a second what's the
point of your call
how can i help you
the point of my call is you push people
into actively managed funds
when over time
if you push people into an index fund
they would have
about 50 percent more money when they
return
okay
um not sure where you went to school for
your math class
but you failed
um
the uh actually compounding
i i understand
dramatically i've been t i got socks
older than you i've been teaching this a
while okay
so uh
this is how this works
now here's the thing you're basically
become doing what bogle said and bogle
invented a wonderful thing with the
index fund and the s p 500 funds are
wonderful index funds are wonderful
they are not a cure-all and there is no
possible scenario unless you're an
absolute idiot in picking your actively
managed funds that you would have 50
percent more
in an index fund now the actual facts
are
more than 50 of the funds underperform
the indexes
that is a true fact to your point that's
a different fact
the fact is two percent two percent
above if if you have a seven percent
return versus a nine percent return
which you have the compounding cost
bringing your return down by two percent
over 50 years you'll have half the money
do the math on that google it that that
would be true too but none of those
numbers you're using are accurate in
terms of what the s p has produced or
what actively managed funds have
produced the actively managed funds that
i personally have picked have
outperformed the indexes by more than
two percent as a portfolio because it's
fairly easy to study mutual funds and
pick them that outperform but if you're
not going to study them and you're not
going to have a good advisor in your
corner then using the index funds is a
great idea here's what we actually found
in the real world versus
versus someone's
hypothetical vacuum discussion of theory
okay
as we studied the largest study of
millionaires
90 of them
a large study of millionaires ever done
over 10 000 of them
ninety percent of them became wealthy
without becoming without inheritance the
inheritance did not cause their wealth
and almost all and almost all of them
did it with their 401k with actively
managed funds now some of the funds
actually underperformed the s p
and some of them overperformed the s p
and some of them used an s p because a
good 500 fund was in there
was in their portfolio as well now let's
go back to warren buffett for just a
second are you aware that warren buffett
does not have all of his investments in
index funds
of course
i'm not sure other than the fact that he
has stated that the average guy because
he's a vocalite the average guy should
buy index funds instead of actively
managed funds other than that he doesn't
actually do what he says he's going to
do with that he actually has an actively
managed portfolio called berkshire
hathaway are you aware of that
yes i am and he's doing it with with the
money he's leaving to his life when he
dies well that's fine
where the money's going's not not
relevant to the mathematical discussion
the mathematical discussion chris is
simply this warren buffett made comments
frequently about the average guy should
buy index funds and i really don't have
a problem with that you can get rich
with index funds
not 50 percent richer that's complete bs
but you know that is true but if you but
you can get rich with index funds i
don't have any problem with that at all
if that makes me arrogant fine but i
think we're confused as to who's
arrogant on this call brother
i think that's the issue i've got a book
suggestion for chris it's called how to
win friends and influence people it's a
classic you should read it
no i mean it's good luck with it i hope
it works out for you but um
here's the thing
i've been doing what i've done doing for
30 years chris and it's maybe a multi
multi-multi-multi multi-millionaire and
i invest in actively managed growth
stock mutual funds that outperform the
indexes across the four types we teach i
actually invest in what i tell people to
do i don't tell people to do something
while i'm investing in something else
different than my friend warren
this is the ramsey show matt is in
lancaster pennsylvania hi matt how are
you
good how you doing dave better than i
deserve what's up
awesome uh first i just want to say
thank you uh in 2015 uh me and my wife
found you and paid off 120 000
uh in 2018 so thank you for that good
for you
yeah look forward to seeing you when the
mortgages paid off awesome
currently
uh i'm a nurse at a hospital
in lancaster that is going to be
mandating uh the coveted vaccine which
i'm not sure if i'm going to get it yet
so i'm looking at possibly doing a
career change
we have an 18 month old and
our second baby is due august 24th
if i don't get the vaccine it would be
my firing date would be september 1st
we're in baby steps four five and six we
have about uh 55 000 in retirement with
my work
we both have iras that have about 3 000
each we're putting in money for
our first child's college fund
monthly and apparently reporting about
400 extra on the mortgage
so i guess my question is how much is in
the emergency fund
the emergency fund right now has fifteen
thousand dollars and what's your
household income
uh
i bring home gross about 63 and then
take home for my wife she intern
business she's bringing
um around like a thousand to 1500 a
month take home
i don't know what her gross is okay we
probably bring home
about 4 500 a month
okay so august
july
and the rest of june
so you've got 75 days
correct yep okay
all right
um
for them to either change their mind or
you get a different nursing job why
don't you just get a different nursing
job
um it's
a shortage one nurse two
i know um so
the
thinking is that's possibility um so i'm
really into finances after discovering
you um and i have been in talks with my
financial advisor about uh becoming a
financial advisor myself
if that would fall through and i'm also
looking at other nursing jobs
the only issue that i see with that is
it's one of the largest companies
hospital-wide
in pennsylvania
on the philadelphia side and i believe
everyone's kind of just watching to see
how many nurses and people leave um well
that's happening that's happening
everywhere okay yeah and the point is
and you you're well aware of this i
don't need to tell you this but i'm just
going to remind you of what you already
know they have there's a lot of places
that have nurses that are not hospitals
yeah that's true
yeah so i guess i could do that yeah
yeah
because here's the thing
here's the thing you need to make the
jump to financial advisor from strength
not desperation and weakness
and yeah so that's my i also yeah so
i've been
offered from other people that know that
i'm in to finances and stuff they have
talked to me about training me to be an
accountant and stuff like that and i
don't want to that's what me and my wife
have discussed i don't want to be taking
any kind of job out of desperation just
kind of like listening to you and stuff
like that
yeah i think you need to finish out
getting real clear on what this next
move from nursing is
and you need to make the jump from
nursing
so what i think is going to happen is i
think you're going to find another
nursing job in the next three weeks
okay
because you're actually going to start
looking
yeah do you think
no do you think i should wait like
say my start date would be in september
no i think i think if these bozos are
willing to put you on the street i'm
willing to put them on the street
okay that's kind of my feeling too do
you think um now with that would you
stop investing because we're investing
15
no i think i'd go get a job making more
than i make now
and quit the bad job with the bad people
okay all right so here's what's
happening okay
this is happening all over america
yeah you know we're we've got large
companies
mandating vaccines and people are
leaving them in droves
okay so hospitals i've talked to
20 people in healthcare in the past
three or four weeks and what's happening
is that they're doing stuff like they're
talking about doing with you and and the
nurses are saying uh uh i'm not taking
this thing
i'm out
i i listen i'm not signing up so
then what happens is they take where
they've already got a nursing shortage
at that hospital and they exasperate it
and then they're once they once they
make the decision then they go back and
undo the decision because they realize
how screwed they are because half their
people walk out it's like causing a
strike
yeah and that's what's kind of going on
here yeah they're i got a feeling as
soon as you find a job
they're going to change their mind
yeah
yeah but i'm not sure i want to stay
there anyway if they're if they're
willing to put the muscle on me like
that
yeah that's so again being in the
financial situation we are thanks to you
guys
um i feel like i can leave well
definitely a lot of my co-workers that
feel yeah you can leave because you can
go make more
yeah because you're in you're in a
fabulous field nursing is a fabulous
field you you know you're only as secure
not as some company providing you
security you're only as secure as your
ability to go land another thing doing
it and nursing you can always land
another thing doing it so you've got
security because of your knowledge base
and because of your licensing
and and because of your willingness to
do what you do and thank you for doing
it by the way
but um
yeah i had a friend of mine the other
day he's working for a huge corporation
he'd been there for years and he was
going to retire in two years and they
said you have to have a vaccine to come
back into the office and he said okay
i'll just retire now
and he's one of their top sales guys and
they lost him
you people in corporate america are
idiots
y'all are idiots
you're just dumb
it's unbelievable and it has nothing to
do with you really think somebody's
going to get sick you're just virtue
signaling
you just want to look like
i'm sensitive you're not sensitive
you're corporate america you're idiots
you treat a guy like this who's been
serving people
like a slab of meat and you know what
he's going to do he's going to
walk on you that's what he's going to do
and that's what you deserve
godly unbelievable
look if you want to take a vaccine i'm
not mad at you but somebody mandating
that you have to do that
or you lose your job
hey they deserve to lose the talent
they deserve for talent to turn on their
heel and walk out the door wire
see around ramsey we got a rule
we don't have a rule
[Laughter]
you can wear a mask if you want to you
don't have to wear a mask if you don't
want to you can take your temperature at
the door if you want to
or you cannot take your temperature at
the door if you want to
and everybody's getting along and nobody
died hitting this is a wonderful thing
and just but just don't be pissing and
telling everybody else how they got to
live
a bunch of people telling everybody else
how they got to live it's a debt mind
your own business
can we talk real estate for a second
yeah let's do so
we were talking during the break about
just even in nashville it's just it's
crazy right now like our friends are
trying to buy houses and they're they're
asking like insane over asking price and
they're still not getting it like it's
just wild so
kovit plays into this
and i know real estate you know you look
over decades and decades you see the
influx of things going up and down i
mean it's just like anything else
but what do you i mean it just feels
like it's insane right now and i don't
know if that's just because we live in
nashville and nationals
it's everywhere so so what does covid
cause people because i would think
coming out of 2020 you almost are more
conservative and you're holding tight
and you're staying put because
it still feels a little unstable right
like we're not even i feel like out of
all the stuff with kovid so
why
why the like why the surge
well several things but
the baseline on it is there's a shortage
on new housing because the lumber
factory shut down
and a lot of the other components of the
house the factories shut down yeah a new
lumber system get lumber yeah and then
when you can't get it it drove the
prices way up on that yeah and uh then
there starts to be a frenzy around it a
feeding frenzy like piranhas you know
it's like crazy and uh
and and so the new housing
slowed to nothing and there's this gap
of six or eight months of production
of the components therefore the new
houses and when you take the new housing
gap
supply out the inventory supply out then
it shortens up the well i can't get a
new house so i got to go buy a used
house and so it doubles doubles down
plus many people looking at half the
numbers of houses and so you end up with
a inventory shortage of new and used
housing and a shortage
always cause i mean you got you know
half the number of houses for sale as
there are buyers out there you know two
to one three to one ratio whatever four
to one whatever the ratio is
then you know that just that alone did
this but the coke what covet did was it
shut down not the real estate market
because people were still buying houses
during quarantine
they were buying them site unseen on
zoom and other stuff right right but but
the uh uh the factory's shutting down
the supply chain getting screwed up has
screwed up the economy so it's not that
there's more buyers it's just that
they're well and then the buyers go
crazy yeah and then the sellers go crazy
yeah and then the buyers go crazier and
so there's this this cycle of just this
feeding frenzy and it's all in motion
and and so you know you're seeing
properties
uh in lots of towns get multiple
multiple offers uh you know fifty a
hundred thousand dollars over asking
prices yeah and they line up through the
whole weekend and there's 62 offers on a
house over the weekend that's not
unusual in a lot of cities right now but
that'll subside it'll just eventually
the feeding frenzy calms down and then
they'll just be this like hangover
uh you know like the housing hangover
after that it'll just be like
like the morning you've felt this ever i
mean for four years i've never seen it
like this exactly yeah but uh in 19 in
the 19 uh what we are going to see out
of this that you've never seen your
generation has ever seen is inflation
inflation the components that make up
the inflation index housing is one of
them it's the biggest part of inflation
and when housing shoots up and oil
shoots up
and oil has shot up too yeah it has yeah
and uh you know you look at the gas pump
oh i know
nobody's talking about it but the gas
pump doubles and housing goes up a bunch
then all of a sudden you're going to see
stuff like i saw in the 70s and 80s
which was double-digit inflation where
stuff's going up 10 15 a year and
inflation was out of control and the
politicians it took it you know it took
some real
strong
politicians to do away with it uh it was
out of control how do they do away with
it well i i credit ronald reagan i'm
just putting the brakes on because it
was out of control under carter and he
comes in and shifted economic policy and
uh just started opening up
doing away with regulation opening up
the markets because if you can flood the
market with supply
it slows down as flows down the feeding
frenzy because if you can get it
everywhere there's no scarcity sure then
the prices start to settle
you know if there's an oversupply prices
go down if there's an under supply
prices go up because there's people
chasing it sure
you know if you you know half the number
of people chasing it as there are you
know you got two houses for sale for
every buyer
well all of a sudden prices stabilize
start to go down start to or at least
quit shooting through the roof
so the out of control upward inflation
so we're probably going to see some
actual inflation out of this which we've
not seen in two decades but in 1982 or
yeah in
1980s under carter the uh interest rates
on housing was 18 percent seventeen
percent i was in in college so
real estate so guess what happened
nobody's buying houses
because your interest rate on a house is
like a credit card that's insane yeah
and so nobody's buying houses they're
all on the sideline going i can buy a
house with these interest rates yep and
so everybody that would have bought a
house that year starts stacking up and
you get pent-up demand water behind the
dam it's getting rid of spill over the
dam and so when rates came down from 18
to
14. i was selling real estate at 22
years old and rates were 14
and there were cars lined up around the
block in the new subdivision
it was like just that four percent i
mean like yeah but but but it was three
four years of nobody buying a house
and the floodgates broke loose 14 was
enough to get them out of their house
yeah and it was like covid they lined up
around the dadgum block buying these
houses and guess what prices went up
interest rates continued to go on down
of course over the years after that we
saw 12 and then we saw 10 and i was on
the radio by then and i'm like oh you'll
never see single digit interest rates
again ever in mortgages well obviously i
was an idiot and didn't know what i was
talking about because we've had single
digit interest rates and now we've had
what we've had for a decade we've had
two or three percent i was going to say
it's like went down
last year yeah you know you watch these
interests
that's the other thing you watch these
interest rates go up with inflation yeah
it'll shut this housing market down i
was going to say how yeah the
correlation between inflation and the
interest if you go from three to six
this housing market will freeze like a
deer in the headlights it'll just stop
people just stop buying they'll just
back up and wait
and uh that's you're gonna see some of
that back and forth now it's going to be
a little rocky
a little volatile but it won't this
feeding frenzy that you've got right
this second is not going to continue
yeah but you do not want to be buying a
house or selling a house right now
without a pro in your corner oh sure
this is not this is not amateur hour
yeah yeah yeah yeah really not amateur
just a bizarre this is how you can
overpay for something or or you know not
get them you could you could be off a
hundred grand on what you could have got
with an agent that knew how to
manipulate the whole process yeah
because it's basically a freaking
auction
in some of these cities on some of these
properties that was one of ours in our
neighborhood the builder
did an auction he was like highest price
and people were like i mean it was it
was
put them out in the front yard crazy i
was like what is happening right now
yeah yeah well that but that's that it's
i don't know if it's just now yeah but
it's an emotional frenzy well that's it
too buying a home
if you just back up and go right now i'm
just gonna chill and watch all these
crazy people finish
and when they finish then i'm gonna walk
back in there because you can't get a
deal in most markets all right today's
question comes from jennifer in kansas
my husband is 100 sure that the world
will end soon or martial law will take
effect and money will not hold any value
because of this he will not save he has
business and personal credit card debt
he has zero savings and spends his money
as fast as he makes it he's up to date
on his payments but has no interest in
paying them off so he can start saving i
am currently saving as much as possible
and will have the last of my debt paid
off later this year
i have life insurance in place for all
of us and a 401k he will also be able to
draw my pension at my old job if i
should pass before he does i feel like
i'm the only one preparing for our
future and honestly it's hurtful
i don't know how to get through to him
that even though the world may end in
our lifetime we should still be
responsible with our money and be
prepared
how can i get through to him
dave
how can she get through to him um
well i mean
the extreme way you've explained him
this is not somebody who's merely a
prepper this is not someone who is
merely
feels like that the culture is uh
deteriorating this guy is so sure
that he's so paranoid that that the
whole thing is going to crash down
that he according to you this according
to jennifer that he is doing nothing
responsible
uh he's just living his life today now
or
he's a complete liar
and this is his excuse for being a
freaking child right and doing whatever
he wants to do
either way this guy is
exercising
at a level of mental illness that is
pretty extreme right
this is a paranoia
situation or it's a depression that is
lapsed into i i literally can't think
through
to to tomorrow so i'm just living for
the next five minutes the next 10
minutes yeah and um i'll create this
narrative and i will find some websites
that will back up my narrative there's
there's a thousand of these conspiracies
millions of them websites and
you know all you gotta do is watch the
news and it makes them all come true
that's exactly right and uh but they're
not you know so um
let me just tell you that that the world
has problems
and uh the world has always had problems
100 of the time and uh but the uh
percentage likelihood of martial law and
of you losing all of your personal
assets coming together in your lifetime
is so small that to believe that 100
percent to the point that it affects
your behavior where you do nothing
responsible for your family is called
paranoia
that is a mental illness level this is
not merely we have a disagreement about
how life works this is you are your
husband is mentally ill and so let me am
i wrong no and in fact here
dave um what i had a seizure in the
doctor in life when um
i had you and i've talked about this i
had mapped out in a very um beautiful
mind kind of way
where this data point led to this one
and this one and i wasn't well and i had
come to figure out that oh the housing
market was going to recollapse and they
were going to have to nationalize i had
created this whole world and so i was
going to cash out this and go do this
and i'll never forget sitting with the
cfo of a 200 million company i sat down
and explained what i was about to do
with my retirement i was going to cash
it out because money's not going to and
i remember him gently looking at me and
saying i don't really understand this
please don't do this and i left that
meeting and i thought he didn't see it
he didn't get it and i'm a guy that
barely knows how to work a spreadsheet
right so here's the thing um when
somebody is in this position the data
and facts don't help a lot
but somebody in this position needs to
go get help yeah i had to go sit down
with somebody and say i'm i'm seeing the
world different than everyone around me
who loves me i need some help yeah and
you're right the world's got problems it
does
one of my close friends gave me a quote
that has stuck with me forever and he
said john i got a lot of plans
but i don't have a meteorite plan if a
meteorite hits us i will deal with that
on that day
and the idea that suddenly money is
going to hold no value and tanks are
going to roll on every street
if that happens i'll deal with that on
that day and until then i'm going to be
responsible and care for my wife who
feels like she's drowning over here by
herself and we're going to go from there
yeah he's not going to give in to that
because it's futile right
just futile
yeah there there's yeah he he needs to
see need help he needs to see a
counselor yeah he needs help so jennifer
no amount of you sitting down trying to
explain stuff to him how can i get
through to him you can't you cannot you
can't because his brain is not
functioning properly right
if somebody in his life that he is
somebody that he trusts that would sit
down with him and say hey let's go talk
to somebody great if you say hey i'm
going to go talk to someone i'd love you
to join me that'd be great um but he
needs to get some help yeah i i by the
way he he doesn't think he needs help so
that's probably gonna be very difficult
so but just to
the point is is that this is not he
isn't you're not gonna solve this riddle
you don't have the tool set i did have a
friend that came and spoke truth to me
my wife spoke truth to me and i wasn't
this bad um but uh that was helpful it
was two people that i trusted and i said
i'm gonna go talk to somebody then yeah
well and i think you might get some
guidance from a a good counselor if you
were seeing one on how to deal with this
situation
because here's what's ultimately going
to happen okay having dealt with couples
in your situation for 30 years
one of two things is going to occur
and there's really not much middle
ground there's not a third thing it's
one of two
he is going to recognize this get some
help and gradually over time get better
and your lives are going to get better
and get more normalized and you're going
to be able to aim at a future and build
build some wealth and get out of debt
and start living reasonably
and you're going to start taking some
incremental not instantaneous but some
incremental steps in that direction
which will give you hope
if that does not occur
100 percent of the time
at some point you are going to boil over
a switch is going to flip
and you're going to be done
and there's there's going to be no
talking you back
because when ladies in particular
are done
after holding their breath for a decade
or for
three years or for whatever when they're
done
you can't switch them back on you can't
switch them back into love mode it's
you're in resentment and that's actually
it's over that's right it's over and uh
because they they've
they reached that i've had it moment and
it's there they really have had it and
they're really gone and so don't let
that happen to you
uh it's going to happen to you if you
don't control the process now you can
control the process and you say okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna give him this
much time i'm gonna try these five
things to encourage him at that point
i'm gonna call this because this
relation i can't be married to a crazy
person
and he is mentally ill darling he's
mentally ill we just diagnosed it um
dave
some of this feels like a
self-fulfilling prophecy to me
that if you get enough people saying
well
money's going to be of no value so let's
just blow it all and run up all of our
debts and go but
that that's the quickest way for money
to have some serious problems right is
that fair i don't know enough about
monetary policy that it just feels like
you're we're starting to see a what
rabbi lapin says he says money is not
actual it's spiritual
so when i give you a hundred dollar bill
the actual paper is not worth a hundred
dollars right it's a spiritual
transaction of trust
and so when i give you a hundred dollar
bill you accept that 100 bill for 100 in
goods and services or you get eyes get
big and you say thank you or whatever it
is because you trust that you can take
that and do something with it
and so what you're saying is and it's a
valid point that if enough people lose
that trust
then the money is destroyed
or if enough people act so ridiculously
i mean if you lose if if 90 of people
lose trust in
the money
the money is no longer currency there
you go there's no current to it right so
i mean i've got some confederate money
from the before the civil war
yeah you know what you can buy with that
nothing right there's no trust
association we have a vested interest in
saying hey instead of running from this
and acting like children let's lock back
and try to get some let's let's kill and
say let's build civilization together
good grief yes today's question comes
from regina in kentucky regina writes my
husband's 86 year old father moved in
with us after his wife passed away
at the time he had over two million
dollars in retirement investments two
years ago he met a woman who's 54. he
has spent well over 800 thousand dollars
on her nothing his children say will
deter him from pulling money out of his
investments to make her happy when we
talk to him about this he says if he
runs out of money we'll just have to
provide for him my husband and i did not
sacrifice to build our retirement just
to support a lovesick old man
what is the family obligation to support
aging family members can i just divorce
my father-in-law
you know what dave i've been doing this
a long time i've never heard that wow
can i divorce my father-in-law a
love-sick old man
she is over this can you tell
dave what do you think about this
about her i think she's pissed i i know
she
is yeah yeah um
yeah it's pretty obvious just see the
the the the email has heat on it yeah i
just set it down it burns
um
this reminds me of an inverse problem
and i don't i don't have a ton of
experience with
um 86 you know 87 88 what we call
geriatric older folks
family members
i always i know that there is a
i feel a responsibility if you will to
to love and support my parents as best i
can the other side of this is it reminds
me of an old henry cloud statement when
you're talking about young kids which is
if he's 15 and he was acting like this
henry would say dr clyde would say he
needs some problems
and the 86 year old who is taking
advantage of his children at this point
and just burning through his money which
he's allowed to do it's his money but he
also has no repercussion for it because
he feels like he's got a safety net so
at some point
it feels like the his kids can make a
make set their boundaries and then dad
with his
1.2 million dollars left gets to make
some of his own decisions
what do you think about that
it sounds fardy feels harsh just saying
that out loud too um no here's the thing
i i
think that we're
called to take care of our family i
agree but we need to define
take care of our family right the
problem with enablers is is that they
and she's not
but uh the problem with enablers is is
that they define help improperly
uh they provide help as being nice and
allowing people to continue in their mis
behavior that's not actually helping
this man correct this man has another
problem okay we everyone hearing this
story through this lady's eyes anyway uh
is really confirmed that this 54 year
old is not attracted to this 86 year old
she's attracted to his money right she's
a gold
he's well digger
his birthday suit needs earning okay i
mean this is this is not an attraction
this is a money thing it's a money play
and um so
you know he's being taken advantage of
are you helping him
by winking and nodding at it
that's enabling i don't think you're
helping him right so i think you got to
love him not be disgusted love him
enough to not be disgusted with him
she's pretty angry but gently and kindly
just say dad
are some consequences
of your misbehavior right
because this lady's not after you she's
taking advantage of you everyone that
loves you is telling you that
and you technically have a right to be
stupid that's not illegal it's your
money it's your money
but you can't live here yeah while
you're doing it we're not going to
condone it and you need to go ahead and
be on notice that we do not feel
obligated to take care of you
um as if you weren't didn't burn through
two million dollars
by giving it to a gold digger and so dad
um if you're going to continue to give
her money you can't stay here and you
cannot expect future help from us now if
you're hungry you can come over and have
dinner
we're not gonna allow you to be hungry
we're not gonna you know but we are not
obligated to support you
while you're doing cocaine right
i always just kind of one of the things
i do in my head if i think i'm being an
enabler because i really people think
i'm just a smart outlet which i am but
they they also you know but i got this
huge heart and i have a real tendency to
participate in people's insanity just
keep going and going i don't know i
think most people do most of us that
love people you know we have a tendency
to do that and i just extrapolate it to
something extreme
and say if he was doing cocaine would
you allow him to stay in your house no
well all that is is another form of
misbehavior
if he was you know if he was boiling
crack in the back bedroom
you know would you allow him to stay
here that's another form of misbehavior
but that's kind of taking it crazy but
that helps you think about
even though this this is a little more
socially acceptable
than boiling crack in the back bedroom
yeah right and so
um you do you do
you'll mess up my poetry but um but yeah
that's uh can i tell you some heat that
i think i feel on this yeah and this is
since regina's not here i think she's
been mad a long time she's been mad a
long time she's mad at her husband for
not stepping in the middle of this
and this is hard
but when you have an 86 year old in your
home with this kind of money it's easy
to start spinning it in your head it's
easy to start thinking man just when he
so-and-so passes away we'll be able to
get this and we'll be able to take care
of that and to see it just liquidating
on somebody who you think has ulterior
motives oh well we all do it just i
think i think i think
i mean i i just i don't think there's
any question about that but yeah yeah
you need to check your own heart and
make sure what you're really he's
allowed to do what he wants to do with
his money but he's not allowed to live
in my house but you've got to draw
boundaries yeah and i'm not required by
moral standards to take care of
someone's misbehavior i'm required to
honor my father and mother which means i
honor the office
of father i'm required to honor the
president
we've had several presidents in the last
few years that i agreed with almost
nothing any of them did right but that
doesn't mean i'm going to dishonor the
office of the of the president of the
united states i can i don't have to
dishonor the office of father
but i can dishonor his behavior there
you go i can disagree with the
president's behavior you can draw
boundaries and go that's out of control
you're acting like an alzheimer's
patient quit that you know i'm not going
to take take direction from you
uh
and so and this is important y'all have
already talked to him you've done the
right thing you sat down and talked to
him he said i don't care
yeah she's more important than you all
are yeah so go go live with her go live
with her boundaries and see how long you
get to stay after you run out of money
not very long yeah about 20 seconds
oh man so that's so sad that is
heartbreaking but yeah you're you are
gonna have to move him out um and your
husband's gonna have to be the one that
does it and your husband's gonna stack
up step up and get a backbone and deal
with this because you're going to end up
really further pissed at him if you
don't yeah you're going to end up losing
your marriage over this you all got to
be on the same page right here yeah and
it feels like
yeah i think while your husband's gone
up to about a three boil you boiled over
she's over
and
uh and you know
you're gonna end up thinking you can
deal with this and it's not it's not in
your
purview to deal with his dad no because
what happens is is his dad's going to go
away and pass away
and then you're going to have to lose
your husband because you kicked my dad
out yeah and um you're going to have a
whole other set of mess right yeah you
got to be together there's a different
script that's going to play then it's
exactly right there's a fun one john
credit card debt keeps falling
and here's a sad note
banks are on edge dave i've got a
kleenex if you need one i have a tear
banks are on edge the banks
americans are paying down this is uh
wall street journal americans are paying
down their credit card debt at levels
not seen in years that is good news for
everyone
but credit card issuers
uh large cart issuers that cater to
borrowers ranging from the affluent to
the subprime say the overall card
balances and thus the firm's interest
incomes are falling to make up for it
issuers are spending more on marketing
and they're loosening their underwriting
standards
which means that you don't even have to
be alive now and they will issue you a
credit card they don't have underlying
writing standards they just give
everybody a card discover said its
earnings call last month that the share
of card balances that were paid off at
the end of the first quarter was the
highest level since the year 2000
capital one what's in your wallet money
said that nearly half of the credit card
balances it had at the beginning of
march were paid off by the end of the
wow
card balances at three companies
including synchron synchron synchrony i
can't even say that which is the largest
issue of store credit cards in the us uh
the three companies say they're down
nine percent seventeen percent seven
percent the first quarter of the year
perspective
card issuers rely on growing card usage
and balances for the revenue
they're wondering if the pandemic trends
will turn into a long-term shift we are
very focused on returning to growing
loans
i love this next line delinquencies
can't get much lower than where they are
we can't beat people up anymore
or otherwise
keep shrinking your revenues come down
margins will get worse if if people
don't keep on screwing up we're going to
make less money guys
okay guys how how can we and i love
going back to this marketing and
loosening so here's what's going to
happen
you're going to start getting these
emails and cards in the mail saying hey
we miss you guys
here's some more money you can just go
spend hey dave what happens if
america collectively said whoa
we got our bell rung
and we said i don't want to be the
little pig in the straw house anymore
i'm going to get my crap together i'm
going to get out of debt and have an
emergency fund i'm going to be the
little pig in the brick house so when
the wolf comes and blows i don't have
credit card debt i don't have student
loan debt i don't have car payments i'm
under control and i got a pile of money
you know what would happen
discover would be up a creek
the economy would collapse no it
wouldn't
the economy would boom let me ask you
this
if you're if you get completely out of
debt
thus you have your entire income to work
with
and you have money saved
for emergencies and saved to buy things
do you then do people then spend less
over the next decade following that or
more
i know in my life we've spent more you
spend more the house i bought was more
the because you're affluent
yeah you're building your you have money
you spend and you spend so this idea
that debt drives the economy is not true
now consumption does drive the economy
but consumption increases
when people aren't broke
so the idea that getting rid of debt in
america and getting rid of this burden
on the back of everyone
is somehow going to cause the american
capitalistic system to completely fail
is asinine
because the reality is when people get
out of debt and have money
they spend more money now they spend it
differently right more intentionally
more wisely but it's not less dollars
being spent on big screens
you get nicer big cities more dollars
being spent on the equivalent of
whatever the consumption is because
you've got the money yep i mean think
about it if you have to really think
about the big screen and this best buy
has to approve you for 90 days same as
cash
and you have to go through a uh you know
an entire portfolio of paperwork just to
walk out with your big screen you
shouldn't be buying the victory well you
shouldn't be buying it but let's say if
you have to go that verse as you go
you know i want one of those uh no i
think i'll take two
and you'll just deliver it to me and
here's the money
who spends more i mean you know no
really i mean you're not you're not
being crazy but the truth is that i make
a lot more money and have a lot more
money than i used to have and i spend a
lot more money than i used to spend well
no duh you know so this
this is the most wonderful news
in the world and i wish i could take
credit for it but we're not a big enough
deal to take credit for it we're a big
deal but we're not a big enough deal to
shift the whole economy yet but one of
my goals in life is to get americans to
start treating the credit card like it's
the financial cigarette
and we are on track baby
but uh the the pandemic came along and
helped me with my goals
because he woke a bunch of you people up
it slapped the silly out of some of you
i think that again my friends make fun
of me for being overly optimistic all
the time
but i think that by and large people are
good and i think by and large people
um when backed into a corner go oh okay
and my hope here is
that everyone got their bell rung
nothing can happen to us we'd forgotten
911 and before that it had been years
and forgotten in 2008 right and
that everyone realized oh this can go
away overnight but this you know this
can be
a segment of america this could be their
emotional great depression yes they're
never again right mike is in pensacola
florida to start off this hour hey mike
how can we help
hey dave and christy thanks for taking
my call how are we all doing better than
we deserve what's up
well
my wife and i are debt-free minus our
house
we have an emergency fund
we're about to start investing in a 401k
and don't worry we do not own beanie
babies
[Laughter]
we're good
so i'm calling about our home we're
looking to relocate to a better school
district and a safer neighborhood
and
you know real estate of course and this
market's crazy i know nothing about it
so we're looking to see if we should
sell now
and buy later being that we have the
available funds for a down payment
and
we have the
a place to live in the interim for free
my father-in-law's house he's being very
generous
um
as far as future predictions will the
market go down later should we sell our
house go live with him and then buy
later what are your thoughts on that
i do not think this is a bubble
okay and that would be the only way it
would go down
i think the you think the craziness will
slow
and the rate of increase in prices will
slow
but i don't think this is a false bubble
that's going to course correct and the
house prices in pensacola florida are
going to go down dramatically anytime in
the next decade
what that means is if you buy and step
out of the most flooding the market but
yeah what that means is as you step out
of the market
every day you wait to get back in the
prices are going up for the rest of your
life
so it's definitely not a good idea to
sell now and buy later it's a good idea
to sell now and buy now
sounds like it nothing nothing nothing
wrong with that because it's an even
swap you're going to get the benefit of
the heated market on the sale and you're
going to
uh have the problem of the ben of the
heated market on the buy so i'm curious
about this dave because we we got some
calls like this last week and i was
talking to you about this even off air
but are you thinking there's going to be
any kind of dip because right now like
nashville specifically with these cash
buyers coming from california so it's so
much people are paying so much over
appraisal and list price you're not
seeing that go down you're thinking it's
just going to level out and then keep
going i mean i'm curious about this
because we we hear about this all the
time the only thing that dropped in 2008
2008 the first time in
my 35 years of having a real estate
license that prices
across the nation went down it's the
only time i've ever seen it was in 2008.
now i've seen particular markets bubble
up and pop
and those have to do with particular
things in those markets
but you know florida does not have any
of those issues i don't um you know for
instance i'll give an example i don't
know what's going to happen in
california yeah because there's a mass
exodus yeah people are leaving
there's there's a stream of u-hauls
going of interstate going down the
interstate leaving the state as fast as
they can possibly flee
and so uh and they're going to texas
tennessee florida uh and buying houses
and so what's that going to do to that
real estate market yeah eventually
if enough of that continues mathematics
tells us that that will hurt prices in
california
it hasn't yet
california is quite hot you put a house
on the market you'll sell in three days
right now in l.a
and so it's not like all these people
leaving have affected there's that
gunman people there that you know that
you you take a while to empty the state
you know and so but they are they are
pouring out of there for sure
and uh those of us that are in the
markets that they are coming to know it
yeah i mean we go out here at the
commercial breaks right here and uh you
know we
i haven't been out of this room to go
out and meet people at a commercial
break i don't think a single time
in uh
five months that i didn't meet somebody
from california that's here looking at
houses i mean every dad gum and so
that's an example of a particular market
that has unique problems in that case
created by the governor
but uh and because covet is not worse in
california than it is in tennessee and
texas and so it's just absolute bs but
the uh uh but the bottom line is you
know and we've seen this before in other
markets where
um
you know something unique happens a a a
a a
manufacturing plant shuts down and it
was a that labor base was a big part of
that market then you can see that market
correct but overall just because it's
going up does not mean it's going to
come down
matter of fact you have a hard time
proving that
you know i i can think back again i got
my real estate license in 1978 i have
seen very few times
that you've seen prices go down from
where they were four months before
and stay down for more than 20 seconds
yeah i just wasn't sure if it was such a
unique situation because of the
amount of overpaying yeah well they're
overpaying
but are they if enough
if enough of them
are doing it that is now the price
that's the new bar yeah and so the
definition when i went through appraisal
class and when i was getting my degree
in real estate the definition of
value of market value is what a willing
buyer is able is willing to give a
willing seller where neither party is in
duress
so in other words if you're buying a
foreclosure that's someone in duress you
wouldn't count that in an appraisal but
if two perfectly healthy situations
and they're paying a whole lot even more
than asking price
then you know where we're getting
multiple offers on a property and that
kind of stuff you know put it on the
market you get 30 offers in a weekend
those kinds of stories are happening all
over then that is the new value so when
people say i'm not going to overpay for
a house
they're not overpaying that's the new
well i mean you know you're you're
overpaying what it's what it's what it
would have brought two months ago right
right right and you're overpaying what
it would have brought monday yeah but by
tuesday yeah i don't know yeah because
these prices are being driven up by this
supply because what has happened is with
the lumber shortage right it's driven
the price of lumber up cost new housing
is going up new housing is also more
harder to get out of the ground
and so we have we have an inventory
problem and so anytime there's a
shortage of anything
and there's more people chasing that
thing than there is thing you that's a
supply demand curve from the seventh
grade economics class it drives price up
yep
that even works with beanie babies
[Laughter]
when too few when too few people i mean
when a big bunch of dollars are chasing
too few things yeah then those things
go up anything that has scarcity in
other words you'd always see the price
go up and so what will happen is is this
market will calm down as the inventory
gets rebuilt as the lumber factories get
to build and get to making lumber again
at the same pace or an increased pace to
offset this and the prices come back are
they at least the lumber prices will
come back down that i do think but
that's not going to necessarily affect
real estate values overall so anyway yes
i i don't have any problem with you
buying right now
or selling right now but i would do both
of whatever you're going to do get out
of the market whatever you're going to
do so i've been dealing with anything
that causes you guys grief for 30 years
here on the radio and if we find
something that gives you grief we try to
help you with it
if term life insurance is the way to go
we try to find a term insurance provider
for you
if getting a high quality real estate
agent is a good thing we try to do that
for you we do not endorse things on this
show
unless we believe in them i don't put my
name or my voice on something merely
for money
and i that the most successful
endorsements that we've done on this
show are things that have to do with a
problem you have and we connect you with
someone that is an advertiser to solve
that
one of the biggest problems we've run
into over the years is people that are
stuck in time shares you can't give them
away nobody wants them you can't sell
them even for a dollar because nobody
wants to take over your fees and your
increased fees and all the hassles and
all the screw-ups that we've been
hearing about this entire hour
so many years ago a couple of young guys
started a company called timeshare exit
team
and they were advertising on a small
radio station or two here or there and
they got in touch with us and said we
want to come on the dave ramsey show
because you hate time shares as much as
we do and we have a way to get people
out of time shares
we have a legal process with a team of
lawyers to bust up into these guys and
to get them out
and so we said all right let's do that
however you guys are small operators and
you need to understand when we tell
people to come to you you're going to
get a bunch of business and you're going
to get your business act together
to say that their business exploded
when i came on the air and told people
timeshare exit team will get you out
is an understatement
their business skyrocketed over the next
few years
resulting in them getting more than 20
000 almost 25 000 people out of their
timeshares
but
the problem was
they were so successful
that two things happened
one is there two young guys running a
business and it's hard to scale a
business that fast and they got where
they weren't returning calls that great
so we're jumping on them because we're
hearing complaints because timeshare
won't call us back timeshare won't call
us back from the customer that's not
okay and it was just because of sheer
volume of business
the second thing that happened
was that they were so successful that
the timeshare companies
they were feeling the pain
it was hurting them
and so mike flasky the ceo
of diamond which has just recently been
bought by hilton windham mike flasky
stands up in front of the arda and says
i'm going to commit a million dollars to
putting timeshare exit companies out of
business anyone who comes at us to get
our cut to make us let our customers go
that we're screwing we're going to put
them out of business
we're going to do it with legal fees
we're going to do it with pr and
publicity we're hiring a publicity firm
we're going to put a team of lawyers on
this and he teamed up with windham and
he teamed up with blue green and he
teamed diamond did
and um
marriott and whoever else they could get
westgate whoever else they could get on
the list
and they decided to go after these
lawyers and different companies that
were running people out of timeshares
and they got they've got they've gotten
bad stories written about people
including they're going after me now
they've gotten uh the attorney general
in the state of washington to uh to try
to prove that there was something false
going on and there wasn't
and timeshare exit team
although hugely successful over the
years uh
has legal fees in the millions and
millions of dollars now trying to defend
themselves against this company and
they've run out of money they're running
out of money
and so they had to pull off of our show
they couldn't afford to advertise
anymore
they run them out of business they're
running them out of business they're not
out of business yet
but they're having to defend themselves
against the uh attorney general state of
washington they're having to defend
themselves against a massive set of
lawsuits brought time and time and time
and time again and all they have done is
get people out of time shares that's all
they've done
and so that's why you don't hear them on
the air here anymore
and then inside edition shows up and
ambushes me for an interview and wants
to know why i'm why i endorse timeshare
exit team lisa guerrera and charlie well
lisa guerrero and charlie even though i
didn't grant you an interview in your
ambush in the lobby of the omni at the
dallas that was so low class you too
you ought to know better than that you
don't think i'm going to come back and
put 22 million people on notice how
scummy you are at inside edition
that was so low class
so i'll answer your question why did i
endorse timeshare exit team because they
were doing the right thing and getting
people out of timeshares after companies
like mikey's had screwed them
that's why i endorsed that company and i
did it with great pride and they got
over 20 000 people out of their
timeshares before the legal fees and the
bogus stuff from bogus government
officials
i wonder how much he was paid
wow
how much were you paid lisa
how much was inside edition paid by the
time share companies
how much did they pay you i didn't know
you could buy a story on inside edition
i didn't i didn't think you all were
that i knew you were tabloid but i
didn't know you were that low
or are you just so dumb
that you didn't understand you were on
the wrong side of this argument on the
basis of the consumer
so this is why timeshare is not on the
air anymore timeshare exit team
but guess who's still on the air
me
me
and i'm sitting
in a 300 million dollar paid for
building
neck deep in cash you jerks
bring it
bring it mikey
bring it you have done poke the wrong
bear you done pissed off the wrong
hillbilly
you have messed with me enough that i am
coming after you bozos and i'm going to
make a hobby out of you guys
and you don't understand how hillbillies
work
we fight generationally
ask the hatfields and mccoys they don't
even remember why they're fighting and
they're still fighting
so diamond resorts hilton you made a
huge mistake investing in diamond
because i'm about to destroy your
freaking investment if i have anything
to do with it at all i'm going to tell
millions tens of millions of people over
and over and over and over again
how bad mike flashkey is as a ceo
how scummy he is and how these companies
absolutely are screwing the consumer
over and over and over and over and over
again
if any of you dave ramsey listeners go
into a diamond presentation after
hearing this i gotta call you stupid
if any of you dave ramsey listeners go
into a westgate presentation after
hearing this and you walk into the tiber
tigers cage in order to get a free pass
to the zoo and pet the tiger hoping the
tiger won't eat you you're stupid i'm
getting a free a free hotel buy your own
hotel
buy your own hotel do you hear the guy
called in in the first segment 22
thousand dollars he invested and used
the thing six times
that's a nice hotel
where are you staying
my god the four seasons in paris france
i mean you can rent out the dead gum
come on people think
think
don't be stupid rednecks and fall for
these people
don't be stupid
these companies are straight up evil
they are sucking the lifeblood out of
america's families and we have got to
stop them from doing it and the only way
to stop them is not legally
they got too much power because they're
buying off lawyers they're running
lawyer you're that guy they're running
lawyers out of business
unbelievable
the guy's having to shut down his legal
practice because he's overwhelmed with
law with court costs and legal fees to
protect himself because he was acting as
an attorney
to get people out
how do you i mean 15 cases that guy's
got right now and that's just one guy
you know how hard it was for us to find
him we found him in 24 hours lisa it
wasn't hard to do a little investigative
reporting and actually find out what's
really going on in this industry
if you were a real reporter
oh my gosh
this is not hard you guys this is not
hard
when something feels slimy you know why
cause it's slimy
so diamond westgate windham
marriott bluegreen
who am i leaving out here i won't leave
anybody out
just let you guys know
you've been hassling my butt for two
years
behind the scenes
and we just made it public game on boys
game on